herzlich willkommen zu einem
wundervollen themen besprechungs video
gedöns dingens zu minecraft war und zwar
ist es so dass jetzt die erste folge
erschienen ist und dass tatsächlich
einige verwirrte kommentare aufgekommen
sind die man vielleicht fast schon so
ein bisschen als held bezeichnen könnte
und ich hab mir zusammen mit dem konto
hallo ich bin auch dabei contra ist auch
dabei habe ich mir überlegt dass es doch
vielleicht für die zuschauer draußen
ganz sinnvoll sein könnte wenn wir da so
ein bisschen die meistgenannten oder
meist christen kritisierten punkte
aufgreifen und in dem video darüber
reden und versuchen die vielleicht ein
bisschen zu erklären also wir wollen
sich übernehmen niemand darf das projekt
scheiße finden dies dass sondern wir
wollen versuchen die die punkte sind
aufzuklären und vielleicht ein wenig
licht ins dunkel zu bringen damit der
ein oder andere gewisse regeln und
situationen in minecraft war besser
nachvollziehen kann
das hast du wunderschöner dankeschön ich
hab's halt einfach schön das kann ich
auf jeden fall wieder geben als team
eine menge
es kam eine menge kommentare die ein
wenig gegen das projekt war
beziehungsweise gegen die grundgedanken
dieses projektes minecraft war wie der
liebe kinos gerade auch schon gesagt hat
wir wollen jetzt nicht sagen
wir blockieren allerdings was gegen das
projekt haben wir hatten euch und dem
ist das gut finden sondern wir wollen da
nur so ein bisschen drüber diskutieren
was ihr eventuell erwartet hätte für ein
projekt und da würde ich sagen das geht
aus direkt schon hier mit dem ersten
punkt anfangen kann genau was ich noch
dazu sagen möchte es ist nicht so dass
luca und ich irgendwie krass in die
planung des projekts involviert waren
also das haben andere übernommen bewahrt
sich diejenigen die die projektidee
hatten sondern sind eigentlich eher
teilnehmer deswegen ist es tatsächlich
so dass wir hier nicht primär uns selbst
verteidigen wollen sondern auch einfach
so die gesamte sache an sich also wir
reden aus der position von einem
teilnehmer und nicht als jemand der das
projekt von anfang an geplant und die
regeln gemacht
sondern halt nur mit gesprochen hat und
mit an diesem projekt teilnimmt ich habe
ein paar punkte auf geschrieben das sind
mit eure kommentare von zuschauern die
unter den verschiedenen ersten folgen
standen
und ganz ganz oft kommt als erstes der
punkt dass das projekt doch viel zu kurz
gehen würde also dass es kein langes
kein großes projekt werden kann weil es
ja schließlich diese todes regel gibt
dass man gleich raus fliegt wenn man tot
ist
so erzwangen erstmal an damit dass das
projekt zu kurze video luca was hast du
denn dazu zu sagen also grundsätzlich
wenn ich zuschauer während sehen würde
oder als neues projekt und haye ist das
geil und euro das ist einfach nur hunger
games da würde ich auch erst mal denken
das ist hier relativ schnell vorbei die
sache ist allerdings dass diese kugel in
der mann ist nicht so ist wie
beispielsweise beim survival games vier
von raidl dass das da nur irgendwie dann
zwei oder blöcke weit geht oder so
sondern das ist ja bei uns das zehnfache
wenn ich sogar noch weiter ist das 2005
bauen entfernt ich glaube sind ich
glaube es sind 1000 1000 blöcke
insgesamt 2.000 4.000 insgesamt
irgendwie auf jeden fall tausende blöcke
die man da erkunden kann
und das zählt ihr auch quasi was ihr
schon in der ersten folge gesehen habt
wir sind ja auf nahezu gar kein team
gestoßen also wir sind da haben ganz
kurze roddick und so am horizont
erblickt aber sonst haben wir auch
keinen da gefunden obwohl 20 leute bzw
noch mehr auf dem server waren also da
spricht der quasi dafür dass das projekt
auf jeden fall länger dauert außerdem
nehmen wir ja nicht immer gleichzeitig
zusammen auf also es ist ja nicht so
dass wir sagen okay wir nehmen jeden
sonntag sieben folgen alle gleichzeitig
auf das kann man gar nicht planen da hat
nicht immer jeder zeit findet man noch
keine zeit wo jeder zeit hat das war ein
toller satz
allerdings ist es halt so dass man zu
verschiedenen zeiten auf oder kann es
halt da kann es mal dazu kommen dass
eventuell drei teams auf einmal online
sind und dann treffen die sich eventuell
durch einen dummen zufall irgendwie
irgendwo und dann kommt
bereits im stand und irgendein team
stirbt dann als kann aber auch sein und
das ist sehr sehr oft der fall würde ich
sogar grob sagen dass man sich einfach
nicht aus dem weg geht sondern dass man
einfach zu verschiedenen zeiten auf dem
zb es gibt leute die neben halt viel
lieber irgendwie nachts um drei vier uhr
auf und es gibt leute die mich und
genoss die nehmen dann lieber ganz
unterschiedlich auch zu menschlicheren
zeiten und dass man geht sich da quasi
unfreiwillig aus dem weg wodurch das
ganze projekt doch ich denke schon sehr
lange dauern wird es wird nur so das
eigene ding dann von kitas und mir und
nicht unbedingt in zusammenarbeit mit
den anderen leuten richtig richtig also
man kann rausfliegen das kann schnell
gehen das kann aber auch lange dauern
also es sind jetzt natürlich einige
leute in der ersten folge gestorben was
diese todes regel dann natürlich so ein
bisschen in schlechtes licht gerückt hat
weil wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle ich
bin ein riesen fan von lg mit cash und
ich freue mich tierisch darauf dass lp
mit cap bei das übrigens ein kleiner
spoiler also schaute letzte folge von
apple mit käfern
das heißt ich bin ein riesen fan und
merkel okay der ist in der ersten folge
gestorben dann bin ich natürlich erst
mal ein bisschen angesäuert tatsächlich
ist es aber so dass dieser clou an dem
projekt eben diese todes regel ist dass
man beim ersten beim ersten mal sterben
rausfliegt damals bei hero wurde die
todes regel mit diesem eine folge
aussetzen auch von anfang an kritisiert
später als ich dann eingependelt und ihr
werdet auch nach und nach merken dass
bei minecraft war das was das projekt
wirklich ausmacht das was die spannung
erzeugt auch für für den youtuber für
den spieler an sich ist diese todes
regel ist wäre keiner aber absolut
keiner von uns in der ersten folge so
dermaßen voller adrenalin und mit herz
punkten und aufgeregt gewesen wenn diese
todes regel nicht existiert hätte und es
war uns allen bewusst dass man in der
ersten folge auch sterben kann das heißt
es ist nichts was irgendwie jemand nicht
wusste das ist jetzt ein versuch dass
wir das für diese todes regel machen und
ich finde das eigentlich ganz
interessant das macht für mich war
extrem spannend
das kann unsere zurückgeben deswegen
warum schaut euch den hunger games an
ganz einfach weil ihr sehen wollt wie
lange der spieler defizite der youtuber
der diese spielweise games dann auf
nimmt halt überlebt wie gute es am ende
gewinnt etc und genau das gleiche ist
halt bei wago war es nur noch weiter in
die länge gezogen weil man es nicht alle
auf einmal aufnimmt bzw
nicht alle auf einmal aufnehmen können
und von daher macht sich mehr oder
weniger wie schon gesagt hat
unfreiwillig aus dem weg geht allerdings
hat das wieder den positiven vorteil
dass der positive vorteil ist auch gut
das hat wieder den vorteil dass man sich
immer mehr aufbauen kann und dann
eventuell am ende
ich würde sogar grob sagen sich
verabredet dass man dann nicht zusammen
auf nimmt aber dass man auf jeden fall
zeitgleich aufnimmt damit es dann zu
einer schlacht kommt wenn man dann
eventuell sagte ja okay wir mit sachen
gefahren wir hätten jetzt mal bock auf
dem feld um uns das hier irgendwie in
die tat umzusetzen
und da ist es halt ganz einfach so jeden
fall fliegt jeder aus diesem projekt
raus entweder man geht als sieger heraus
das projekt ist vorbei oder man wird von
einem anderen team getötet und ich denke
gerade wie cross karts auch schon gesagt
hat das ist einfach dieser anreiz an
diesem an diesem mai kreft projekt dass
diese todes regel einfach dabei ist sie
das auch schon gesagt dass dieses
adrenalin wir am anfang nicht vorhanden
gewesen wenn es so gewesen wäre die bei
ihrer beziehung mit dem megaprojekt wo
man einfach respawn drücken kann und
dass man direkt wieder dabei das geht
hier nämlich nicht
man kann sich nicht einfach betten
machen und dann wenn man tot ist mal
wieder bei seinem bett und hat seine
sachen wieder nein man ist einfach
komplett raus und das finde finde ich
zumindest ist dieser faktor weswegen man
sich immer sagt otto hilfe ich liege
lieber die ganze zeit weil ich angst
habe dass ich in la valle das ist finde
ich ein richtig guter spartak st das
deckt da ist natürlich auch der punkt
wenn du jetzt grad fieber oder das
megaprojekt erwähnt dass da viele sobald
die folgen anzahl höher ging oder den
dreistelligen bereich habe viele immer
wieder kritisiert dass es immer
langweiliger wurde und eintöniger bei
minecraft waro und das ist was was viele
vielleicht auch noch gar nicht sehen
wird sich die situation von tod von
folge zu folge zuspitzen
das projekt wird nicht langweiliger das
projekt wird spannender weil immer
weniger leute in dem projekt drin sind
und somit immer die anzahl der
teilnehmer immer kleiner wird und das
ist auch so ein faktor der glaube ich
die
das fortschreiten des passt das des
projektes sehr spannend gemacht und ich
habe da jedenfalls bock drauf und die
ganzen anderen youtuber die da mitmachen
hatten logischerweise auch bock drauf
und vielleicht haben wir da ein bisschen
vergessen diese faszination dieser regel
zu kommunizieren aber das ist jetzt eben
minecraft warum ein kraftfahrer hat
diese regel die das ganze besonders
macht und das ist auch direkt die schöne
überleitung zum zweiten punkt weil sehr
viele drüber geschrieben haben jetzt
habt ihr das projekt groß angekündigt
und das ist es eine große runde survival
games ernsthaft geht es noch um
innovative und manche haben das auch in
dem ton gemacht wo ich mir echt gedacht
habe okay vielleicht mal ein bisschen
respekt gegenüber denjenigen die das
geplant haben weil was man vielleicht
vergisst sich wirklich mal ins
gedächtnis zu rufen ist dass ihr 40
youtuber mitmachen 40 leute für die ein
gemeinsamer termin gefunden werden
musste
40 leute die da mitmachen wollten 40
leute die für die zuschauer interessant
sind die planungen die regeln wie das in
dem kampf was ist mit combat logging wie
viele folgen davon am tag bringen wie
lange dauert das all diese planung
drumherum ist viel mehr als einfach nur
ein survival games nun das ist das
grundgerüst ganz klar ja ich will jetzt
nicht sagen das ist ein neuer minecraft
spielmodi ganz so gar nicht aber dieses
ganze gerüst drum herum dass das ist das
ist ja schon aufwendig an sich ja die
sache ist vor allem auch das natürlich
wenn man sich jetzt so denkt zurück
diese regeln dafür habt ihr so lange
gebraucht um minecraft hero die sache
ist halt für euch wirken die regeln
simpel man sagt okay man ist direkt raus
wenn man steht sonderregel muss
allerdings eine woche lang diskutiert
werden damit alle davon überzeugt sind
dass es ja nicht so dass jemand in
unserem verein schreibt und sagt hey ich
bin für die und die regeln dann hey ok
super filme sind wir auch alle dafür
sondern es müssen ja natürlich so
einschränkungen getroffen werden wie
beispielsweise das mit dass man ungefähr
im rahmen von 15 minuten bleibt wenn man
was hochlädt das habt ihr bei allen
gesehen das haben auch mehrere schon
gesagt dass man dieses diese in diesen
spielraum von 13 bis 17 minuten dann
beispielsweise und die anhalt immer so
perfekte zeit gefunden dass es nicht zu
langweilig wird allerdings auch nicht zu
kurz die folge und es sind quasi alles
sachen die man
auf dauer besprochen hat also wir haben
uns da jetzt nicht 30 stunden am stück
an den konfi gesetz und das alles
durchgesprochen das ist ja unmöglich
sondern das wirklich nach und nach
geplant und da muss auf jede person
rücksicht genommen werden wenn
beispielsweise jemand in den urlaub
fährt gibt es sonderregeln dass das
hochladen angeht das sind alles sachen
die jedoch gar nicht alle sitzt als
zuschauer sondern direkt ein paar
darüber urteilt so nach dem motto
einfach sowie games ich kann auch
einfach und server mit 40 freunden
machen oder eine runde spielen das ist
ein bisschen was anderes was wir hier
machen da geht es ganz ganz ganz ganz
viele regeln und ja es ist einfach ich
finde es ist super durch plant genauso
wie michael das war minecraft niger über
das erste das war solle das war seine
art zu unseren anfang so wie kommt das
überhaupt an wenn man mit so vielen
leuten spielt ist dann am ende ein
bisschen ausgeartet und zwischendrin
auch aber rio war ein perfekter
fortschritt danach was allerdings mit
der zeit auch langweilig wurde da
einfach in alu krieg herrscht und man
sich nicht auf den server traute
allerdings wird es bei war einfach so
dass man eingegrenzt ist das heißt man
kann ich die ganze zeit weg laufen und
es ist einfach super durch plant auch
mit dem server nitrat ist ein großes lob
das die das hingekriegt haben das
natürlich ein bisschen länger am anfang
das ist natürlich klar wenn 40 leute auf
dem server sind jetzt eine menge raum
hat aber nicht so einen guten prozessor
dann ist das natürlich
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich ist das ist sogar
punkt nummer drei er weil er viele
geschrieben haben dass es mit denen mit
denen mit den lecks das ist nicht so
cool war und dass man doch bitte die
leute wiederbeleben lassen sollte die
halt durch die lecks gestorben sind
was ihr da auch nicht wissend dass wir
vielleicht auch noch mal irgendwie
hätten sagen sollen ist es so zum einen
diese lex hätte man natürlich absehen
können weil viele leute in viele
verschiedene richtungen rennen und die
chance generiert werden das war uns
allerdings in dem sich bewusst dass
natürlich niemand vorher viele haben
dann geschrieben hätte doch meine
testrunde machen können
ich sag nix nur mit viel haben
geschrieben vielleicht hat das ja nur
zwei drei vier fünf leute geschrieben
ich habe die kommentare natürlich
überflogen und mir auch die rausgesucht
die viele bewerbung hatten also ich
spreche jetzt natürlich nicht alle leute
an und möchte menschen an den pranger
stellen das sind eben nur die punkte die
mir aufgefallen sind über die wir
sprechen möchten die vielleicht ein
öffentliches interesse haben dass du
noch mal so als kleine einschränkung
dass sie uns nicht falsch versteht wir
wollen niemandem irgendetwas böses wir
wollen euch nur helfen das projekt
besser zu verstehen also zu den zu den
lecks das hätte man absehen können
es sollte sich allerdings niemand im
voraus die map anschauen es sollte auch
keine test
runde geben es sollte eine komplett
unvorbereitet spannende erfahrung werden
und deswegen sind diese lex zustande
gekommen von denen wir dachten dass sie
vielleicht ausbleiben weil wir einen
extra starken server die stadt dafür
zusammengeballt haben von von mikado
das ist dann passiert ist ja das ist
eben so gewesen dass leute vielleicht
auch mit durch diese lex gestorben sind
ist in dem sinne ist aber da auch
bedenken dass auch die leute die diese
person getötet haben die hatten ja
ebenfalls genau das internet leute die
gestorben sind das lag ihr einfach
wirklich an den server richtig genau
genau das wollte ich sagen und wir haben
dann natürlich danach haben wir direkt
besprochen
okay leute da waren jetzt sechs am start
wie machen wir das ganze und wir haben
uns dann auch mit den leuten die in der
ersten episode gestorben sind sportlich
darauf geeinigt dass es okay ist dass
wir die erste folge so belassen und
nicht noch mal neu aufnehmen weil das
problem wäre gewesen hätten wir neu
aufgenommen während andere leute in der
ersten folge gestorben so dann hätten
die leute die ansonsten die dann dadurch
gestorben sind dass wir neu aufgenommen
hätten hätten dann sich vielleicht
beschwert er ja wir haben neu
aufgenommen der eigentlichen ersten
folge bin ich nicht gestorben was soll
das jetzt und die leute die gestorben
sind in der ersten folge die jetzt
online ist die haben sich nicht
beschwert haben dass sportlich
hingenommen was ich übrigens auch total
cool findet also man hier ein riesiges
lob an all die leute die uns leider in
der ersten folge schon verlassen mussten
weil das macht er seine das war keine
keine diskussion von drei stunden
sondern das war uns klar dass das jetzt
die erste aufnahme ist wir alle wussten
man kann in der ersten episode sterben
man kann von uns gehen ja ich weiß was
dem extra dramatisch für dich und bitte
schön
und ja das heißt viele zuschauer haben
sich hier mal wieder stellvertretend für
ihren lieblings mit über vielleicht ein
bisschen zu sehr ein versetzt alle sind
miteinander cool ja es ist nicht so dass
diejenigen die durch lecks gestorben
sind dann nach drei wochen heulend in
der ecke saßen und so weit habe gar
nicht vor so aufgenommen aber er ist ja
ihr versteht was ich meine also wir
haben das alles schon besprochen und
deswegen ist hatten ja alle die lecks ja
das hat er ja nicht nur ein irgendwie
die lex lugar und ich haben zum beispiel
manche konnten am anfang von holz
abbauen oder gar nicht was eine allianz
da und wir haben gesehen
ich lief mit alle bekommen dass die holz
alle bekommen holz und wir stehen da und
hallo wickelt der neubau hat das
natürlich auch sportlichen genommen
ermittler geschrieben ja wir können kein
holz abbauen
es ging ja dann noch nachher zeit also
wir haben uns jetzt auch nicht so groß
beschwert auch in der sache wo es jetzt
uns beschweren geht und zwar am anfang
wurde ich ja vom ist amor game geboxt da
habe ich kommentare bei mir unter der
folge gelesen also ich habe in der
aufnahme nichts gegen ist am morgen
gesagt ich habe einfach gesagt hey warum
bleibst du dich an einfach so mit der
hand was soll das wenn einfach
weggelaufen und dann geh doch selber
gestalten ist der morgen gesehen habe
seine folgen arbeitet also kinos kommt
nicht auferweckt das ist eine ganz
normale hunger games situation wenn ich
in der situation ist am morgen gewesen
wäre und hätte den spieler gesehen von
dem man weiß ist ja nicht so gut im pvp
ist wäre ich natürlich direkt drauf
gegangen hätte ebenfalls zugeschlagen
das ist eine total richtige aktion
gewesen vom ist am morgen nur die sache
ist dass das von euch ich möchte jetzt
wieder nicht jeden hier irgendwie wieder
schon sehr schön gesagt hast an den
pranger stellen
aber es haben einige leute bei mir
darunter geschrieben ich möchte jetzt
auch keine namen in istanbul gehen ich
hasse dich du fette stück schaltet erst
mal atmen warum tötest du wachst du
direkt von crafter jedoch mit einem
titel wohin so was in die art etwas in
die richtung wo darunter geschrieben und
da denkt doch einfach leute es ist
hunger games
ich meine natürlich ist es auch immer so
wenn man wenn euer lieblings youtube
jetzt in der hunger games gestorben ist
beispielsweise auf verschiedenen server
wie die half dann werden natürlich die
leute geld die euren lieblings youtuber
dann getötet haben
da sagt man also höhe vor bis auf das
aufgehört mit der hand direkt am anfang
so einen spaß niebler 111 aber
allerdings ist dass der ganze aspekt von
diesem von diesem micro dass man halt
leute töten muss mehr oder weniger damit
das projekt ein
sinnvollen abgang findet bzw mehr oder
weniger erhält das projekt fortgesetzt
werden kann dafür müssen halt leute
sterben
und deswegen war die aktion von ist am
anfang komplett richtig obwohl da
wirklich viele leute darüber geredet
haben deshalb auch viele bei anderen
leuten geredet
zum beispiel bei kev weil er am anfang
im gestänge getötet hat und dann haben
sie ebenfalls bei kev gerettet weil er
nicht verstehe ich weggelaufen ist
also das sind alles sachen wo ihr denkt
ja ich habe das so viel besser gemacht
und ich werde weggelaufen und alles wir
hatten in dieser situation einfach einen
puls von 180 und habe einfach versucht
alles richtig zu machen wenn wir das
nicht hingekriegt haben entschuldigungen
aber da muss man nicht auf uns rumhacken
und vor allem behandelt und mit respekt
beziehungsweise die verschiedenen
mitspieler und schreibt da nicht so was
drunter wiederholen so ein boxer dich
direkt
man musste ja auch beachten dass es
wirklich und das haben wir auch schon
hier erwähnt das ist role play ist das
ist nicht umsonst in dieser also wo ist
ja die abkürzung für vanille role play
so wie hier wo die abkürzung für hexe
powerplay war
und wenn das ist darauf ausgelegt dass
wir uns betteln er das ist darauf
ausgelegt dass man dass man
gegeneinander kämpfen und dass man sich
gegenseitig tötet und das ist ein
kompromissloses hartes ding wird und das
klingt irgendwie egal
aber wenn ihr mich versteht es geht
einfach darum dass man dass man sich
hier bettelt und das ist in etwa so also
wenn ihr jetzt anfangen mister x games
also den wir jetzt hier leider
komischerweise anderen als beispiel
nutzen die mir keine ahnung in folge 10
greift den er mich an
ja und dann nehmen wir die
unwahrscheinliche situation dass
die mehrheit an fängt den zu helfen und
dann ist es aber so als würdet ihr zum
beispiel in gzsz bringt personal person
b um und ihr hättet den schauspieler
dafür dass er das getan hat es ist in
gewisser art und weise immer noch dass
das ist einfach ein konzept das wir hier
fahren und da ist auch immer ein stück
war dieses wohl play dieses schauspiel
mit drin
und deswegen sollte man nicht die
direkte die realistische person dafür
fertig machen dass er was macht was in
diesem spiel mit inbegriffen ist das ist
dann also dass das gehört einfach nicht
mit dazu ja auch mal sagen
genau deswegen ich würde würde jetzt
gleich schon zudem zu einem fazit
rüberkommen was sie nämlich auch noch
sagen wollte das ist natürlich jetzt das
was wir anhand eurer ersten kommentare
irgendwie erklären konnte selbst auch
nicht jeder voll gemacht genauer
genommen sagten richtig stellen auf dem
was ist es ist ja früh das projekt zu
beurteilen das kann es natürlich sein
das ist doch auch ein bisschen schneller
vorangeht als wir das jetzt hier voraus
gesagt haben ich glaube allerdings auch
dass es seine zeit gehen wird weil das
projekt ist ja erst am das ist ja erst
am start wir können ja selbst noch nicht
wissen ob das projekt jetzt mega episch
wird oder ob es vielleicht doch am ende
nach 20 folgt man sagt okay da hätten
wir vielleicht dies und das ein bisschen
anders machen können aber so ist es halt
auch für euch zu früh nach einer folge
bewerten zu können ob das projekt ein
reinfall wird oder nicht
deswegen haben wir jetzt gerade einfach
nur mal versucht dass wir da ein paar
dinge erklären könnte hier vielleicht
ein bisschen besser verstehen können und
wo das ein oder andere aufgeklärt wird
weil ich das so ja ich habe einfach das
gefühl gehabt dass viele der kommentare
er aus aus aus unverständnis heraus
entstand sind als jetzt irgendwie aus
dem direkten rumhängen oder rumtollen
bei manche waren auch wirklich in
ordentliche rechtschreibung und
ordentlicher kritik und trotzdem haben
sie hat vielleicht ein bisschen aus
seinem unverständnis basiert und
deswegen wollten wir einfach mal nur
freundlich hier ein bisschen erklärungen
schaffen denn uns beiden oder zumindest
eigentlich macht ja allen allen youtube
macht der minecraft war wirklich riesig
spaß
wir versuchen für euch nur ein mega
gutes mega spannendes projekt auf die
beine zu stellen das ist ja das was wir
wollen wir wollen nicht irgendjemand auf
die palme bringen
wir wollen einen meter ist ja nicht dass
wir haben uns ja nicht von anfang an
gesagt okay wir machen jetzt ein projekt
wo alle denken höher als das scheiße wir
halten euch unser ziel war einfach dass
es allen gefällt und das ist mal was
anderes ist alle hätten jetzt wieder mit
so etwas wie hero gerechnet vielleicht
mit einem anderen motto pack etwas
anderes das kann ja auch
kommt das hausgemachte traditionell das
habe ich mich auch darauf freuen
eventuell gibt ja so was in zukunft auch
normal
zwinker aber es ist auf jeden fall so
dass wir jetzt mal was neues plan
wollten ausprobieren wollten und bisher
kommt es bei den meisten gut an wir
haben ja sogar so ein paar negative
kritik volle kommentare rausgenommen
haben da ein bisschen drüber diskutiert
wir wollten ja wie zum dritten mal schon
gesagt niemand an den pranger stellen
wir wollten einfach nur kurz die
kommentare zusammenfassen unsere meinung
darüber sagen und wir können das auch
noch gar nicht prognostizieren wie lang
das projekt geht was ich da noch alles
verändern wird eventuell wie du gesagt
hast liegen wir auch falsch und wir
sterben schon in der zweiten folge oder
dritten ich weiß nicht wann wir dieses
video hochladen werden muss man einfach
abwarten
das ist halt der charakter des projektes
ihr könnt euch jeden tag denke folge
guckt media oder nicht diese person ich
weiß es nicht
das ist halt so das tolle an diesem
projekt finde ich genau und was wir zum
abschluss noch ganz wichtig ist was ich
sowieso immer auf youtube betone ist das
vielleicht manche oder diejenigen die
sich jetzt angesprochen fühlen müssen
die fühlen sich auch angesprochen so ein
bisschen an ihrem ton in den kommentaren
arbeiten gerade was gegenüber den
youtube angeht wie gesagt conny und ich
sind primär und hauptsächlich teilnehmer
in diesem projekt wir haben da jetzt
nicht groß die regeln mit geschrieben
oder mit geplant also wäre natürlich mit
diskutiere mit gesprochen aber wir haben
nicht mitgeschrieben oder mit geplant
dass am anderen übernommen
und dass man da einfach nicht auf
diverse kanäle geht und da rein butt
ohne ende und das ist es den fünf scheiß
projekt und einfach wirklich wochenlange
planung und bearbeitung wo diese
menschen sehr sehr viel rein investiert
haben die einfach so so mies behandelt
das finde ich einfach irgendwo unfair
weil das hauptziel von jeden in diesem
projekt ist wohl von den planern als
auch von den teilnehmern euch gute
unterhaltung zu liefern und ein tolles
projekt und euch den dental zu
verschönern mit diesen folgen und
spannung zu bieten
und wirklich was tolles aufzubauen und
wenn das eure meinung nach nicht
geklappt hat dann es kann auch einfach
sein dass manchmal wirklich das projekt
einfach objektiv nicht gefällt dann ist
es so aber dann muss man nicht
irgendeinen unschönen ton gegenüber den
beteiligten und verantwortlichen
anschlagen das wollte ich noch so als
als letzten kleinen display mit
dranhängen aber das ist ja auch nicht
die mehrheit ja wir haben jetzt hier
sind hier noch ein paar extremfälle und
auf ein paar unklarheiten eingegangen
und
damit vielleicht ein bisschen licht ins
dunkel gebracht wenn dem so sein sollte
wäre das super wenn das alter wird mich
freuen wenn vielleicht einer hier
irgendwie sagt ja das hab ich jetzt
besser verstanden und da ist mir einiges
klar geworden
würde ich auch sagen ich hätte auch gar
nicht mehr zu sagen ich würde einfach
laden dank fürs zuhören wenn jemand
dabei sein weil das zeigt ja dass ihr
ein bisschen toleranz zeit und unsere
meinung auch versteht und dadurch sagen
video die mitte und habt ihr gesehen
diakonie und ist uns die ganze
gegenseitige fresse einer urwahl
bestimmt